London, 1983.
Good afternoon to you.
Well, it's decidedly parky
to say the least.
And, in fact, it's not gonna get
any warmer, really, in the next few days
because we're going to keep
these north to northeasterly…
[McCusker] I certainly remember the day
because it was cold and miserable outside,
and I was sitting in my office
when a colleague of mine told me
that he had been called
to Cranley Gardens,
where suspected human remains
were pulled out of a manhole there.
When we got there, the tenants
were standing around the manhole.
The toilets had been blocked,
and an engineer had been called
to clear the drains,
and he discovered
huge amounts of flesh and bone.
I have a limited knowledge,
but very heavily suspected
that it wasn't, um, animal, shall we say.
[interviewer] Did anyone express
any particular interest in what you found?
Yes. The guy, I believe,
was living in the top-floor flat.
[McCusker] Then the tenants told me
that the previous evening,
around about midnight,
they had heard a scraping noise outside.
When they went to the front door
and opened it,
they saw the man from the upstairs flat.
He was dressed in just a simple vest.
And bearing in mind,
this was February, freezing cold.
And they asked him if he was all right.
And he said,
"I am. I've just been outside for a pee."
I made further inquiries
at Cranley Gardens
and found out he was
at the localJobcentre where he worked.
And he normally returned from his work
at half past five every evening.
We then found out
that the pieces of bones from the drains
were indeed from a human body.
And the pathologist said
that the piece of flesh
appeared to have
strangulation marks on it.
[tense suspenseful music playing]
[McCusker] And lo and behold,
we saw a man walking up the road.
[Nilsen, singing]
♪ Oh, the time is coming ♪
♪ The time is coming! ♪
He was very calm indeed.
[Nilsen] When I arrived
to Cranley Gardens,
the police were unsure of their ground.
They were fishing tentatively
in the hope of gaining information
concerning the samples of human flesh
found down the house…
…drains.
Nilsen then said, "Very strange
that police officers should come
and talk to me about my drains."
[camera shutter clicks]
[McCusker] But he let us into the house…
[McCusker]
…and we went up to the attic flat.
[camera shutter clicks]
[McCusker] And as soon
as he opened the door,
the smell just came at you.
[camera shutter clicks]
-[camera shutter clicks]
-[McCusker] I knew that awful smell.
So we said to him…
[Nilsen overlaps] "Stop messing about.
Where's the rest of the body?"
And he looked at me,
and he pointed
to the wardrobe.